manille côté vitrine sa baie touristique
ces promenades et ses quartiers
d'affaires manille une mégalopole avec
ses enfants des rues
venu de la banlieue ou des lointaines
campagne ce sont des enfants abandonnés
drogué battue qui voit dans cette ville
la promesse d'une vie meilleure
on estime qu'ils sont entre deux et
trois cent mille passants leurs journées
à errer monde y est volé dans cette
ville qui n'est plus qu'un mirage sans
espoir
ils font partie du décor c'est à peine
si l'enfer temps sur elle
pour couper la faim ces gamins annales
de la colle ou fume du crack
une façon d'oublier un peu la galère une
image ordinaire à laquelle les autorités
philippines ont décidé de s'attaquer
cacher cette détresse qu'on ne veut pas
voir
c'est depuis quelques temps le credo
officiel
alors pour nettoyer les trottoirs la
mairie a mis en place un service de
ramassage
curieux mélange de travailleurs sociaux
et de policiers
[Musique]
en
c'est ici loin du centre ville derrière
ces murs barbelés que la mairie a décidé
de cacher ces pauvres deux bâtiments
vétustes une prison pour enfants et en
face le rac
oui ça pionne action center un centre
social d'accueil en fait une prison qui
ne dit pas son nom ou son parc et toutes
les personnes ramassés dans les rues
une majorité d'enfants des mamans
esseulé et beaucoup de vieillards
options
[Musique]
pas
en
cela fait quinze ans que dominique lemay
intervient ici tous les jours avec sa
fondation virlanie forte de ces trente
volontaires bénévoles père dominique
comme on l'appelle ici et c'est de
rendre la vie des enfants plus
supportable le rac a commencé en fait
dans à la tire de la prison pour enfants
de manille dans cette prison il y avait
donc deux cellules à ce moment là et on
met en danger les enfants qui avaient
été détenus avec l'enfant qui venait de
la rue et en 1992 j'ai découvert que bon
il y avait ce bâtiment là qui étaient
bâtiment qui était en très mauvais état
donc on la refait pour pour en faire une
un accueil pour les enfants des rues ce
qui évitait les que les enfants des rues
soient incarcérés
donc ici dans la dans cette prison pour
enfants
aujourd'hui activité décoration et
nettoyage pour les enfants le rac fait
peau neuve
on attend une princesse caroline de
monaco princesse de hanovre est ici en
tant que présidente de l'association
mondiale des amis de l'enfance l'amade
dont la fondation virlanie fait partie
alerté par dominique elle bien se rendre
compte elle même de la situation mettant
tout son poids dans la balance pour que
le droit des enfants soient respectés
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
élevé
le maire de manille en personne ces
déplacés pour l'événement
à la grande surprise des résidents du
rac plus habitué à le voir sur des
affiches qu'en chair et en os
le protocole est bien réglé et même les
enfants prisonniers se prête au jeu
ça
[Applaudissements]
il faut dire qu'en échange d'un bon
accueil en aura premier une séance de
basket
ils sont entassés à plus de 50 dans une
cellule sans savoir quand ils sortiront
beaucoup sont ici depuis plusieurs
années à part certains qui ne sont pas
des anges le seul délit de ces ados a
été d'avoir traîné dans la rue
[Musique]
bon
the western écrit paul klee soit sur le
baseball ou jamais
bombardements
isbn s'adonner le soleil de satan
après la prison visite du rac
ici le plus vieux pensionnaire à 81 ans
le plus jeune à peine âme
c'est fait
on
[Musique]
il ya un sacrement
vivant il s'est fondu à 4 ici parce que
la mère avait rendu les défis
versailles le réseau local et partie de
l'or pourrait être vendu par sa mère
actions et l'autre en fait d'aucun et
protégé ici ce qui pour éviter justement
le
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non les c'est d'avoir une promesse
concerne la plupart des sorties sortir
hoarau
hummer
grâce au travail de nuit
moment
[Musique]
exactement six nations charlie parce que
le lendemain de la visite de la
princesse la vie retrouve son cours
normal l'ennui la routine reprennent le
dessus ce l'animation de la matinée le
ballet des fourgonnettes blanches qui
déposent leur lot quotidien d'enfants
ramassés dans la nuit des enfants
déboussolé au parcours compliqué que les
autorités locales ont bien du mal à
comptabiliser
là a priori en ce moment la rumeur ne
sais qu'une rumeur c'est que le maire de
magny et voudrait faire en sorte que
tous les gamins soient fichés la perte
auriez tous les gamins des rues avec
leur donnant une genre de petites cartes
d'identité pour pouvoir contrôler en
fait les arrivées d'enfants qui viennent
de province qui sont potentiellement qui
vont potentiellement devenir des enfants
des rues à manille et le fait d'avoir
des enfants condé zaidi donc il ya cela
ils sont à manille on sait ils ont leurs
valises dans leur papier on essaye de
les renvoyer en province parce qu'on
alors immatriculations etc et tous ceux
qui viennent et qu'on passe est à dix
ils vont être renvoyés directement à la
périphérie de manière mais seulement
[Musique]
à savoir
sanaa
donc là par exemple c'est un gamin qui
s'enfuit de chez lui
bon a priori un problème de famille etc
donc c'est un peu le truc classique des
enfants dé réussir qu'il s'enfuit parce
que les prix sont battus ou la famille
ya tellement d'enfants car ils peuvent
pas ils peuvent pas le nourrir par
exemple il n'est pas il n'y a pas de
considération c'est assez loin espèces
digne orangé gamin voilà voilà
bye
l'apprenant
ce que l'abonné
ce qu'ils veulent c'est ce bar est en
fait ils pensent qu'à une chose se
marier il ya des choses qui s'enfuit
d'ici quelques jours france voit sa voix
capa voilà
or
être mère wae mcee
parce que il pilotera une vie moins dure
[Musique]
bye bye john crowley ça c'est fait
maichan
m on veut être policier parce que lui il
est gentil donc ça pas policier gentil
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ces gamins ils arrivent pendant trois
quatre jours ils sortent pas donc
enfermés dans les cellules de sa
soi-disant un temps d'adaptation c'est
en fait c'est pour formater les enfants
pour éviter qu'ils s'échappent web
[Musique]
mais beaucoup ne sortent jamais et
restent isolés toute la journée comme
les ados de la prison ils ont mis au
point entre eux un code un langage des
signes qui leur permet de communiquer de
cellule à cellule
[Musique]
le reste du temps est occupé à manger
dormir s'ennuyer dans des cellules
exiguës où les centimètres carrés sont
âprement disputé
le pacte avec les adolescents aux
prisonniers a été respectée ils ont
droit à leurs parties de basket mais le
temps est limité
tout est fait pour éviter de les
mélanger avec les plus petits ceux du
rac emmanuel un autre volontaire veille
à ce qu'ils se croisent le moins
longtemps possible
basket-ball practice et 5 pilar hockey
et ça fait là en fait ces enfants ils
sont la plupart du temps dans des
cellules enfermé et c'est le seul moment
de la journée où ils peuvent où ils
peuvent sortir et se défouler parce que
difficile c'est que dans les cellules ya
à peu près une cinquantaine
une cinquantaine d'enfants de cet âge là
et on est obligé de faire un choix c'est
à dire qu'on est obligé de de choisir
entre 15 et entre 15 et 20 enfants par
par périodes d'activité et on est limité
à 2 heures chaque enfant peut peut
dépenser pendant deux ou trois heures
par semaine uniquement à ses tours
les petits bouts d'choux rails dans des
t-shirts qui font deux fois alors des
fois leur taille
quelquefois quand ils courent ils sont
obligés de tenir leurs shorts parce que
leur short est beaucoup trop grand pour
eux en fait ils ont une une vie vraiment
difficile mais quand ils jouent sont
vraiment des enfants et je prends
beaucoup de plaisir à faire du histoire
avec des clauses yes man alors lui en
fait cet enfant c'est un enfant qui est
handicapé alors ici on l'appelle on les
appelle des outils salon m'a dit aussi
que c'était un psychotique
alors cet enfant fait il partie pas du
tout aux activités parce qu'en général
il est toujours dans sa cellule il passe
son temps à pleurer et absolument aucune
prise en charge le problème c'est que
y'a j'ai l'impression que le staff ici
et pas forcément formés à s'occuper
d'enfants handicapés donc il est
complètement livré à lui-même il n'est
pas du tout simuler et il se retrouve
complètement seul à l'engueulade mots
voici on aime à 90 pendant l'amour oui
et 1 to play est en tout point
ok on est passé de vol what is nigh mais
voilà derrière et asie le petit garçon
l'a donc il a dit que c'était un
psychotique
alors en fait ici on les appelle par
leur nom par leurs particularités alors
c'est comme les personnes de couleur
1 on les appelle les les [__] lui on
l'appelle un psychotique et souvent les
appels et specials les enfants spéciaux
c'est comme en fait il n'avait pas
vraiment pas vraiment d'identité sans
attaches familiales sans papiers
beaucoup de ces enfants ne connaissent
même pas l'homme en général
l'administration laurent dona composé de
quelques syllabes
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
en dehors de ces deux heures de basket
hebdomadaire la vie ordinaire du rac
c'est ici qu'elle se déroule la cour les
couloirs et les cellules
en
[Musique]
cela fait trois mois qu agnès est ici
sans aucune nouvelle de sa famille
seul moment d'évasion la lecture avec
son petit frère d'un magazine que nous
lui avons donné
c'est tout
comment
en cours ne seront que sa main à nous
[Musique]
nous allons
on ne
plaisir à la note globale n'a pas passé
je veux pour nous ça va concourir à papa
on appelle ça nous a fait mal à passer
grâce à lui conforme là ça va s'arrêter
mais avec kad et o pourquoi maroc pour 2
milliards notamment carole et l'otan
nous bombarde pas dépasser deux familles
des jeunes où doit parler mme x un édito
la bei à peu ça rendrait pas compte de
ce monde un poireau nabab les connais
pas
et au sol un
m
à voir
j'achète beaucoup changé
bon moi je peux dire les panneaux à nos
propositions
allez courir une heure pour l'oenologie
[Musique]
agitation inhabituelle dans la cour du
rac
une quarantaine d'enfants se trouve
soudainement embarqué dans la
fourgonnette de la mairie choisi un peu
au hasard sans explication
[Musique]
thomas
on a découvert une serre de
désintoxication
les potins obligée elle s'y est enfoncée
c'est ce qui s'est passé les derniers
jours ils ont fait des restos michel jeu
les gars est utilisé signe de la cote
il fut déjà bon c'est l'équivalent du
craft précis et il les emmène tout cela
et c'est assez curieux c'est qu'ils
arrivent à 1-2 dans l'espace
al étage agnès a compris son petit frère
se trouve parmi les enfants
le seul lien familial qui lui restaient
vient de partir elle sait qu'il va
retrouver un enfer encore plus terrible
et qu'elle ne le verra pas vingt six
mois dans le meilleur des cas
un retour qui dépend du bon vouloir des
autorités locales
[Musique]
prendre soin des enfants est une
activité excitante mais cas suivez les
parce que nous croyons le maire pense
que les enfants de mali représente la
plus grande des ressources et même s'il
y a des enfants des rues des accros à
l'alcool
même s'ils sont abandonnés négliger il
reste notre ressource
c'est pourquoi nous travaillons dur pour
leur donner un avenir meilleur parce que
le maire de magny da considère que
l'espoir de notre pays ce sont ses
enfants même si vous les voyez comme des
enfants des rues
cela reste des enfants à la différence
des pays européens où certes vous avez
des endroits magnifiques avec des
cathédrales de belles églises des musées
mais vous ne voyez plus d'enfants et
michel dhalenne et moi on passe par
exemple france il paraît même que vous
avez plus de chiens et d'enfants décès
[Musique]
pour dominique et son équipe de
volontaires c'est un rapport de force
permanent avec l'administration
philippines
[Musique]
un combat quotidien jusqu'au moindre
détail comme ici avec un retard de
réparation dans les années terre
alors arrêtez par yvonnick dans les
chutes les garçons ce parce que le tour
se casser la gueule qu'ils ont fermé la
semaine dernière chez epic et ma glande
parce que jenny quand il était en bord
réunion là tous ensemble
le stade de la de l'équipe est en
réunion
moi je suis monté j'ai vu 70 ou 80
enfants d'adam l'avant pièces du aulas
sous une chaleur épouvantable ou un toit
en tôle voyez qu'il peut se passer
ablo mére là dedans et je crois que là
il ya tout un travail qui quitte à faire
donc l'équipe de salaire et la de cette
institution comprennent que bon c'est en
restant assis sur leurs chaises ici en
bas que dans la condition des enfants on
changera on enferme
on n'a qu'à resserre et puis on se rend
bien
aveyron on met à cana comme ça bon ben
on a la paix quoi mais ça fait rien si
une bague à l'intérieur toute façon on
n'est pas dans le coup mais qui donc un
régleur problème même
ouvrir éveiller l'esprit des enfants ne
pas les considérer comme des numéros
c'est toute la mission de la fondation
virlanie qui a réussi à imposer une
salle de classe au sein du rac les
enfants des rues apprennent les
rudiments oublier un peu l'univers
carcéral et peuvent même de temps en
temps s'inventer à notre avenir et rêver
[Musique]
oui
en
autre nécessité la santé la fondation a
pu enfin ouvrir une petite infirmerie
il y a quelques mois
et il sait il avant de partir en fait
que les social alors faire le même
ailleurs donc c'est vraiment tapé contre
nous fracasser la main et du bras ok ok
là c'est la première fois que je vois
quelqu'un qui s'automutilent de la sorte
pour toi à partir du rac en fait donc
mais ça m'étonnerait pas bien on est
plusieurs qu'ils le fassent mais c'est
vrai que la plupart du temps ils
préfèrent que dans les rues qu'ici
[Applaudissements]
pour line une volontaire néo zélandaise
il ya urgence du matin au soir
[Musique]
ces journées n'ont plus de limite dans
les pathologies sont nombreuses et
variées
hop
un peu tout quoi vers les petits qui ont
juste un petit morceau de peau rare chez
un peu de la lotion rosé est un bijou et
ça va alors extrême j'ai vu une femme
qui qui qui meurt est devant moi par
terre elle avait perdu conscience
elle avait un grand concert chou fleur
de st elle avait 2
de liquide baird qui sortaient de la
bouche et de lingettes ou elmer est
devant moi comme ça
je pense que si tu n'entends se disait
elle a fait une chute
oui ça genou qui n'est pas utilisé pour
des cons l'immobilisme la santé de des
gens ici c'est un peu artiste invité
c'est pas la postérité les priorités
sécurité de
du système
c'est pour ça que le
j'ai rien dit justement être lui une
propose en plus
qui était passé l'on négligé crois que
c'est important de savoir quand les
chaînes dans leur comportement c'est
vrai que dans harry volonté à madiba
caisse pour fou qu'est ce qu'on fait là
mon équipe aussi de salariés de la
fondation me dis mais qu'est ce qu'on
fait au rac
on n'a qu'à les laisser faire mais on
n'a pas le droit de laisser faire on n'a
pas le temps
parce qu'en fait qu'est-ce qui se passe
si on les laisse faire déjà les droits
des enfants sont pas respectées beaucoup
alors si on part je pense qu'ils sont
plus respectées du tout hein on est là
aussi pour les bousculer
je crois beaucoup à sambre
là
et pour bousculer les autorités
dominique mise beaucoup sur la visite de
la princesse qui les a placés devant
leurs responsabilités
un signe à la fin de la visite
le maire s'est engagé à faire un geste
pour les enfants avant noël pour noël de
quelle année
moi je peux vous assuré aujourd'hui que
j'ai tout faire on va se battre ensemble
pour que ses rêves et ses promesses
faites à la main à la princesse soit
réaliser les rêves
cela fait longtemps que les enfants
perdus de mamie non plus mais un coin du
voile a été levé
va-t-il se refermer agnès elle attend
toujours des nouvelles de son petit
frère